foreign
comes from Brandi in Colorado she says
I'm 42 and a single mom of a 16 year old
I had to withdraw all of my retirement
to help cover unexpected medical
expenses I'm a renter no retirement
savings now and live paycheck to
paycheck I just received two job offers
and I don't know what to pick option one
full-time working for the federal
government with awesome retirement and
benefits with an annual salary fifty
seven thousand option two full-time
corporate job with an annual salary of a
hundred thousand and a 401K with a match
of three percent should I accept a
higher paying job to help me pay off the
10K in credit card 20K car and 2 000
monthly rent in Colorado or should I
choose the federal government job with
stability and good retirement
I would like to be debt free in three
years so I can move to another state
where cost of living is more reasonable
and I can purchase a condo or town home
for myself well Brandi thank you for the
easiest question of the day that I've
ever had to answer it's absolutely
number two and it's not even close I
think the word here in your two
questions it's got you hung up on this
because this is so obvious to George and
I to take the corporate job where you're
making almost double and that doesn't
even include potential raises over the
next couple of years
and the match of the 401K but the word
George in this question it's got her and
other people they kind of get stuck on
this can I guess it yeah go for it
stability you nailed it they think well
it's a government job
so the government's always going to be
here
and there's no way they're going to lay
me off and that first of all that's just
not true so uh it's absolutely number
two take the full-time corporate job
with the higher salary opportunity to
get raises beyond that and the 401K with
a match of three percent you're going to
pay off that debt in no time
you've got 30k in Consumer Debt if you
take this job for 100k that's 43 more
than the other job would have paid and
you said it's going to take you three
years making 100K you can pay off 30k in
one year and by the way you're still
going to be making forty three thousand
dollars more every single year that
corporate job probably with more upward
Mobility to make even more yes and let
me just say this I there listen
government works are good people that
listen to this program watch this
program and you're in government work
but this idea that it's so much more
stable is a complete myth and you just
don't have the opportunity for growth
that I know